foreign
Chicago hi Daniel welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave hey what's up
hey uh so
um I recently got married I've been with
uh my now wife for about 10 years
um she's going to graduate dental school
in uh in May she's
so she's bringing in about 750
000 in student loans
um and uh other than that she's got a
yeah I'm sorry what is her degree what
did she go with 750 000 in debt for
uh dentist oh Jesus Murphy
yeah it's a good school but it's
expensive
um you have no idea what you just said
yeah
um but uh yeah it's I've got about 40
000 in debt from what seems like you
guys call normal debt credit cards car
stuff like that
um and uh
I mean she's gonna make good money you
know but it's just I can't see the light
at the end of the tunnel you know it's
it's how do we dig ourselves out of that
hole
and he said she's graduated or she's
still well she she will graduate in May
does she have a job lined up or what's
your plan for after graduation
um so I'm not too Savvy on all that
she's waiting for some sort of
she's waiting for some sort of thing
that she needs before she can start
applying um it's pretty much is like her
credentials
um to show off to Future employers so
she's waiting for that before she starts
applying but in the market she's been
looking already it seems like she's
going to start off somewhere between 175
to 225 a year
okay well here's the thing
um
I can tell by the
language you're using in your sentence
structure
um that it is you guys have not grasped
how devastating a situation you're in
and with that
um
what a huge mistake this was
and part of solving this is going to be
that you say out loud and she says out
loud this what what has happened here
it's in the review mirror and I'm not
trying to shame her but you have in
order to run away from a problem you
first have to realize that it's a
problem
and um the language you're using is
minimizing this like you owe thirty
dollars to somebody or something and
it's no big deal but it was a good
school it's not a good school
she paid double what she should have
paid
for her Dentistry degree double she got
screwed yep she got screwed
and you guys are up a creek you're in a
real mess so if you will live like your
absolute poor people
and go make 300 or 400 000 between the
two of you you can pay this off in maybe
three years and get your life back or
you can be a normal dentist and keep
this around for the next two decades
and that's what most dentists do
the dental degrees are the most
overcharged overpriced degree of every
degree out there right now and this one
is double the normal one wow